[MUSIC PLAYING]
I really love the
Imaginary Foundation.
The Imaginary Foundation
is a think tank,
a clandestine, mysterious
think tank in Switzerland
that has created
apparel as a conduit
to spread the power
of human imagination.
Now, what's most amazing
about the Imaginary Foundation
is the mesmegasmic, psychotropic
dimension of its imagery.
The places that
the images convey,
the places that
they induce inside
of the viewer, the cosmic
wink that reverberates
in your very being when you
consume the imagery just,
to me, is astonishing.
Wherever that place is that the
artist behind that is privy to,
thank you for sharing a
twinkle of that reverence
with the rest of us.
Here's to the director of
the The Imaginary Foundation.